[Applause]
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening your patience is
commendable
we knew this was going to go long but
who knew we're going to go
into maybe tomorrow morning maybe even
longer
but look we feel good about where we are
we really do
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
[Applause]
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
[Music]
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
we believe one of the nets has suggested
we've already won
arizona but we're confident about
arizona that's a turnaround
we also just called it from minnesota
and we're still in the game in georgia
although
that's not what we expected
and we're feeling real good about
wisconsin and michigan
and by the way it's going to take time
to count the votes we're going to win
pennsylvania
[Applause]
i'm going to talk to the folks in philly
allegheny county scranton
and they're really encouraged by the
turnout of what they see
look you know we can know the results
as early as tomorrow morning but it may
take a little longer as i've said all
along
it's not my place for donald trump's
place to declare who's won this election
that's the decision of the american
people but i'm optimistic about this
outcome
and i want to thank every one of you who
came out
and voted in this election and by the
way chris coons and the democrats
congratulations here in delaware
hey john you're the gov yeah like the
whole
team man you've done a great job i'm
grateful
to the poll workers to our volunteers
our canvassers
everyone who participated in this
democratic process
and i'm grateful to all of my supporters
here in delaware and all across the
nation
thank you thank you thank you and folks
you heard me say it before every time i
walk out of my grandpa's house up in
scranton he yelled joey
keep the faith and my grand mom and she
was live y'all know joey spread it
keep the faith guys we're gonna win this
thank you thank you thank you
your patience is great let's walk over
[Music]
[Applause]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
now
tomorrow thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you